From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Okay, so today is Friday the 21st of June 2013.
Speaking as David Klein from the History Department at Virginia Tech,
also working with the Southern Oral History Program.
Behind the camera today we have John Bishop from UCLA and Media Generation.
And today we have the absolute pleasure of speaking with Professor Scott Bates.
And we're in his lovely home in Swan, Etenicee today.
And if you could just introduce yourself, that would be wonderful.
Okay, I'm from Chicago, Evanston actually, close from Lake Michigan.
And I went into the Army from my college, that was drafted in 1942.
And went straight to Camp Grant.
When were you born?
I was born in 1923.
In 1923 in Illinois.
And my whole family is from Chicago.
And my great uncle was Lincoln's best friend.
He's not his best known friend.
This part of book I loved was from New England actually.
And he went west to Chicago.
Here's a farm boy.
Went west and became a Chicago lawyer.
And the rest of my family is Chicago Lawyer History, up until parents' sterile.
We replace him high-grandfather.
But my great uncle was a fellow from his name was Sweat, Leonard Sweat.
And the book has just come out about him.
And he went west to Chicago, as I said in those days.
He became a lawyer.
The rest is my history, basically, a bunch of Chicago lawyers.
And I ended up in Northwestern because Evanston was dry.
Right.
And they were dry Englishmen.
And so before they were made.
So I grew up in a dry town and was delighted to find out that
I came to a dry county, which was running with good moonshine.
Of course.
The best moonshine ever ended up in Chicago in the trucks of Al Capone.
So everybody knew Al Capone.
If you want to go to Al Capone restaurant, it's in Mont Eagle Tennessee right down the road.
And it's the part that the rest of the food in town has some of the best liquor in town.
And then perhaps the whole range here came from this road and this woods.
The stills were here.
So anytime any police wanted some good liquor to drink, they'd rated it away to still.
And drink the liquor for the next month or so.
And so this is well known for its liquor and I'll give you a shot.
I was putting them in a day.
Well let me ask you, if you could just sort of sketch the journey that ended with you coming here to Sohane.
So you talked about growing up in Chicago a little bit about where you went to school.
I guess we're drafted.
I don't know if you're drafted into the middle.
Yeah.
I went to Carlton College because it was relatively cheap.
And it had no fraternities.
And I lived across the street from Northwestern University, which was a drunk and university
at that time, and was glad to leave it.
And so I was happy to be at the Sober University.
But I was also happy to get my first job after the war.
I was drafted in 1942 and sent to England to France to D-Day and as a French interpreter.
As I'd spent the interim at the University of Chicago, studying French for the Army, ASTP program.
And I studied that for a year, sent to Britain, which was the Harniest Island I've ever wanted to go.
And everybody's sleeping with the landlady going to build it.
And the landlord's kind of, we're working in the factories so they didn't care much.
And they were getting ready for D-Day.
We all knew D-Day was coming up.
So we landed on the beach at Omaha Beach and a land beach, what they call it.
Beach driver, no land driver.
The land drove to what it called.
Anyway, the land in the middle of a firestorm.
They didn't have air cover.
But they had night cover.
I mean, they had air cover at night, but no Americans didn't have air cover at all.
And so they blasted the hell out of us, literally lying on the beach.
And I woke up in the hospital last week on the sand on the Utah beach.
The sand in my hair, I can feel it.
You could feel it when you woke up.
Yeah, and it was right there.
And so we were, as soon as Patton broke through, we headed down to San Lo on the halfway down to Avansh,
which was our ultimate goal.
We were going to be in the military government of Avansh, which was called at that time.
The Patton's Third Army, it was going like a house fire, but they held up at San Lo.
So they sent over 1300 bombers, big bombers, and bomb the hell out of San Lo for half a day.
And we reduced it to rebel, nothing but rebel.
There's a little museum and chapel there now.
And then when we broke through there after about three weeks, we had a straight down for Avansh,
which was our rendezvous with the Badles Army and went in with Patton's Army in the Brittany.
But Avansh was our goal.
It was there that I became a French interpreter and did French interpreting for the rest of the war, until we got to terminate that.
And that was for a year before we made the breakthrough in Germany, the Badle of Balsch and all that.
And we kept out of the Badle of Balsch because we were French interpreters.
And we were expected to run Germany.
We were going to be the people who ran Germany.
And so we were saved at Womile France, Womile Sissin, is what I really ran into the black troops.
They were stationed there for the winter, before the Battle of the Balsch.
And they were all sent into the Battle of Balsch and everybody was sent into the Battle of Balsch except us,
because Eisenhower depended on us to run Germany.
And so we kept out there for a year supervising the horror houses in France.
And that's where I ran into a lot of black troops, because they were separated, they were separate but equal.
And it was mostly equal.
It was mostly equal.
It was more than equal actually because they had nine horror houses, but they were not supervised.
They were not legal.
And we had charges of the legal horror house.
And so we had two horror houses.
They had nine horror houses and all the horror they wanted, the black troops had.
They were secret.
And there's never been tale told about them.
But they had huge pain.
Those stories wouldn't have been inspected though.
They were not inspected.
So that would have been more dangerous obviously for them.
So I've never heard about the rage.
It must have been an epidemic of syphilis among black troops at the time.
And Connery and everything else.
Because we kept the arched white guys down to the two black horrors at the horror house.
And they were black?
No, they were white.
Oh, white horrors.
Yeah, white horrors.
Yeah.
And they were a business woman.
I mean, they ran town practically.
Yeah.
Because they had long lines waiting for those two white gals, you know, became millionaires out of that.
And so they must be legendary.
And someday, the story was being written up.
But it was of course another Paris, what happened in Paris.
And there we went to one of the horror houses because they were full of white, black, everybody.
And French soldiers and white British soldiers and...
Gosh, everybody, Spanish soldiers, you remember.
I mean, Spanish.
Emigrated soldiers.
And in any case, because of Franco's time, you know.
But in any case, that was interesting because we walked...
We asked the people where we went in for a load of tiles because tiles had been blown off all the roofs
and I...
And I...
Center of Avalanche, which is the key point between Brittany and Normandy.
And that's where our station was.
And so we were assigned Avalanche.
And we thought whether it was going to be there for a week, or a patent's army went through.
But they held up at breast.
We watched San Lo burn across the bay.
And what was that out in the middle of the bay?
But this beautiful fairy castle turned out to be the most sandy shell.
Didn't know it was there.
Never heard of it, you know.
What was that fairy castle doing in the middle of the bay?
And so we stayed in Avalanche for three weeks while Hitler did a counter attack,
which has not been written up like D-Day.
It was about like D-Day, you know.
And so we were at the middle of it.
So that was the worst part.
That was the worst in D-Day for us, lying on the beach.
And we were bound...
A shit out of, frankly.
It was just incredible.
And everything Hitler could throw at us.
And this generals could throw us.
They were against it.
They knew they'd never break through patents out.
To the sea and they never got to the sea.
They never got to a most sandy shell.
But the usual sandy shell is a target site.
That would imagine you buying.
They stayed at the dive bombing on us.
And that was the worst part of it.
That was worse in D-Day, actually.
Just focusing on this little town, you know.
And blasting the hell out of us.
So we got out of town and went to a convent on the edge of town.
And stayed in this convent.
And the outhouse in the back house of the convent.
It was a sergeant, a staff sergeant.
And he brought along a little French gal who had been...
had her head shaved because she'd been sleeping with Germans.
And so we stayed with her in the French gal in the sergeant.
And two PFCs.
And me, there was the French interpreter.
I was the only one who spoke French.
And so I was necessary to the bunch.
And so we left that...
stayed there because they didn't bomb the convent.
One thing they were after was the little bridge across the little river there below Avarage.
Where the whole Patan's Army was going across.
Guided by five MPs and a couple of AKXs.
And boy did they get it.
And no protection really.
No cover, you know.
And so we went under the same bombing, meaning the town next to it.
And that was the worst bombing.
That was even worse than the D-Day.
But that's... it's he-it's not been told.
Let me ask you about...
That's called the Battle of Falez.
Falez Gap.
That looks...
Yeah, that's the next bombing.
Let me ask you...
Just about race again.
So you mentioned the interactions that you had, obviously, with the black troops.
Probably other interactions that you had there.
What about... were these your first interactions with black folks?
Or had you had some growing up in Japan?
No, they positioned them in the same little town.
All meese is Sen, up on the top of the Sen, where the Sen begins.
And we had to cross the river to the Hore House.
But the Hore House was strictly for whites.
And the black troops found their own Hore houses, built their own houses.
And they had about... because they got into fights with the white troops immediately,
if they went to the White Hore House.
They were in the moment they arrived, they separate, of course.
They were at that white Hore House.
And immediately the fight started with white southern troops.
And of course white southern offices.
They put southern offices.
And black troops and white troops, so we had to separate them.
And the black troops were relegated to the...
the hores in the town, of which there were hundreds on the sidewalks.
But they were not supervised.
They were not legal.
And the white hores, two white hores, were legal.
So it was directed the white troops, the white Hore houses, two white hores.
And the black troops, there must have been 20 to 30 hores.
They were not... they were white hores, but they were in the black Hore houses.
Supervised by black.
So I walked MP with one black who was a sophomore at Lincoln College in Pennsylvania.
And it was very airy-dite.
And we talked English literature.
And it was a third black, a third white MP who was a Virginia.
And he couldn't talk to us, because we were talking literature.
And he couldn't talk literature.
I could talk four letter words, but that's a...
And so he said...
When we went into a bar and I gave his free drinks, our MPs, and sat us down on tables.
And we were different tables from us too.
We were both English majors.
And so we talked 17th century English literature while he'd cuss away with...
He couldn't talk French either.
And this black guy could talk French, and I could talk French too.
So we ran the show really.
And so we didn't arrest anybody.
And nobody arrested anybody.
Everybody had slept around, you know.
And so the black saw got syphilis, and the whites did not.
And we'd gone a rear of whatever they had.
Mostly gone a rear.
Now had you gone to school with black folks growing up in order to...
Oh yeah.
It...
And Black.
She was rather dead.
It was higher thanreb OPENS.
I...
Tell you the truth.
September onwards, in a building there tried to gather around the place of French They protected the White dogs.
They needed to hold the camp, and then they were running plates at this place where they have devised their rights.
And so...
And so that was all right.
But I used to go down the Howard Street,
which was on the edge of Chicago to have drinks.
And everybody else, and I did too.
And it was my first question.
It was quite a cost of street.
And my question was the drunkenness place
in the whole area.
And so that grew up with.
It's the drunkenness street, white, white,
I read in the blacks in high school.
And the drunkenness place in town, Howard Street
between Chicago and Evans.
Well, so I was used to that.
And so when they got my first job after the war,
I went back to Carlton College.
And did very well in Carlton College,
because I'd had 12 months at the University of Chicago
learning French to become a French interpreter.
And so I got my first job at Swaney, Tennessee.
And they were looking for a job.
It's hard to get jobs at that time.
Same thing as now.
And so I got a one-year job in the French department.
It's Swaney, Tennessee, a boy's school in the South of America.
And in the North of Italy?
Have you ever been to the South before?
Yeah, one time in Orangeburg when I was a kid for my health.
And I got to know that Southern.
But I never saw black in Orangeburg, South Carolina.
Not a one-black.
It didn't have black mage.
You had boarding schools, didn't have cabins or roadhouses
or anything like that.
So we waited around a big table, you know,
all the food on the table.
And everybody ate there, but all white.
And maybe black servants were white here,
old black servants, and so on like that.
And since they did their couple of months,
and that was my one experience.
With the South.
And then my experience with blacks was in the Army.
And in the, in Evansville, Illinois.
We did have a black maid in Evansville, Illinois,
because in Evansville, the blacks would arrive from Chicago
every morning on the L. And the whites would go into Chicago
for the jobs.
And we never saw a gangster.
And this was in the 20s.
And when I was going up.
So in any case, ended up in Swan, Tennessee,
little town of 400, little college, or 400 male students.
And the year.
And the year was 1954.
After I got out of, I got 16 years of GI Bill.
And got my PhD at the University of Wisconsin
between that time and that's why I,
and went back to Carlton for a year,
and went to the University of Chicago.
Went to to University of Wisconsin to get my PhD.
And then from there, at my first job, it's why I need Tennessee.
And so that's how I ended up in the 20th Tennessee.
And that was no blacks, no women, boys, college,
physical college, and it was hired for one semester.
Well, they saw a smoke-good trench.
And so they hired me for lifetime, actually.
Turned down.
And I'm here still here in Swan, Tennessee.
It turned out, my work to do on the board of directors,
trustees, actually, at Swan,
a ballboy school, all a physical school.
And I was brought up on eighth-year cognizant,
I was basically.
And so did do my best job to convert the school.
And not only from, well, it turned out
that most of the faculty was unitarian,
either a physical or a physical or a engineering.
And the student body was about 90% of a physical pain.
And about 90% segregationist.
So no blacks.
But there was the physical church,
which had made a sense of being desegregating.
And it was mostly run by the trustees
who were a physical priest, half of them.
And so there was a big battle there.
Until 1943, when the whole white trustees,
or a white faculty walked out of the Swan, Tennessee.
And the University of the South, there was known as,
and took in what they thought were southerners for faculty,
faculty trustees, about 90 faculty.
Well, maybe 60 at that time.
And so we did our best to help them desegregate.
And we brought in, we desegregated because the
black seminaries, physical seminaries
throughout the South were closing.
And they had to send those black, physical,
or would be priests to some place.
So they sent them to white seminaries,
including the one across the street from me.
In Evans, in Illinois,
Seaberry, Western, which was a conservative one,
and across the street from the Methodist seminary,
which was, I mean, that was, which was Seaberry Western.
That was Garrett Bibb.
Garrett Bibb, where Rosemary Ruthie still works,
who she's a Catholic.
And in any case, they were very liberal.
In the fellowship of reconciliation,
the best was organization, headquarters there.
And in Evanston, there's a dry town,
right by the Lake Michigan,
which is why we have a lake next to us right here,
at the top of a mountain.
This is my ideal, have a lake at the top of a mountain,
no, in the middle of a pine forest.
And so we settled here and had been here ever since.
Now had you had any interaction
with the fellowship of reconciliation?
Yeah, I joined in Chicago.
I joined the Chicago chapter.
And what kind of work were they doing?
They were doing anti-Vietnam War work,
about that time.
They started in Vietnam, anti-Vietnam War.
Yeah, at War work.
War work, yeah, anti-war work.
And the fellowship reconciliation headquarters
was in Chicago.
So I went down from Evanston every Saturday
to go to their meetings.
And read in John Swamley,
the great John Swamley,
the great theologian,
passively theologian of the fellowship of reconciliation.
He came there for our out of Kansas to meet with us.
And so the fellowship reconciliation
played a large role,
but it was of course Christian.
And I wanted something with non-Christian.
So I joined the fellowship,
I left the fellowship of reconciliation
for the war of the Stooges League.
We said the Stooges headquarters
in down Greenwich Village.
And where John,
Mac,
John Mac,
he has a radio,
he has a,
what do you call him?
A station,
you know,
a blog.
Every day you can hear him.
You can contact,
if you want to contact with all the wars
this is action going on in America today.
Very interesting, still.
He gets about 10,
and they call it blogs today.
And they're all on Google.
You can Google John Swamley.
And not John Swamley,
John Mac,
you know that name?
No.
Yeah, he's kind of elder
statesmen to the wars.
He's just,
he's touched with all the socialists action in America now.
And the anti-war movement.
And all the anti-
war movement in Egypt and their places.
So you had some disconnection to the fellowship
reconciliation,
which was interested in racial reconciliation.
Oh, yeah, very much so.
Before you came to this area,
just to say what?
And then I got a call once I got this job down here.
I got a call from a Bertron,
not Bertron,
Bernard,
excuse me,
I like a memory now.
I was asking.
Beard wrestling.
I got a call from a long distance in my office in Swamley,
saying,
we hear you collect anti-war poetry.
He said, been doing since I was in high school.
And do you still have that collection?
And I said,
yeah,
I'm still doing it.
And I'm doing it for the wars this year's late now.
And I got a column in,
and I had a couple of poems in their periodical
and fellowship,
fellowship reconciliation.
And joined the wars this is league.
And now I have a lot of poetry of anti-war poetry.
He said,
well, can we use your collection of anti-war poetry?
And they said,
yeah, I said sure, of course.
well, we'll put out a calendar every year.
Or is this a league calendar?
And we'd like it for a poetry, anti-war poetry.
So I said them all my anti-war poetry.
For the next guys,
anti-war poetry from my first one was 1956.
It's all there.
1966,
to this desktoped a couple of years ago in 1980,
1986 I think was.
And they had a poem in every anti-war calendar.
So they got a collection,
they published that collection in poems of war resistance.
We sold 13,000 copies.
That's your book.
We made a book to invent more.
They were preaching it from Hebrew,
Pasophist, Pulpit, and the American.
And it was great.
I just read your book of poetry,
calling for my love for this.
with them all over the country.
They have it in my library and everything.
They're teaching in one of my courses down here and so forth.
That became famous and tried over there.
They had the great artist from Vermont, the drawings and that change and everything for
it.
They sold all of the books to liberal books.
That's exciting.
So I'm still using it.
I put out a poem a week here on all the liberal courses of course in our local newspaper.
In the local newspaper here in Swansea?
Yeah.
Which was typed and published by my wife for the first 18 years and then taken over by
the Swansea Mountain Messenger which is coming out and you can pick it up at the way
you eat lunch or in your face.
Right.
Anyway home.
So I always have a poem in it.
I was wondering what's going on.
The war, the, I tried to keep it fairly calm but do good funny poetry.
But it's related to the anti-war stuff and memorial day and things like that.
Of course the July I was having a fourth slide poetry which is an armistice poetry.
Right.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And so forth.
And so that's read by everybody.
It's free.
It's handed out.
And so everybody reads this.
The first the Swansea Reen it was called the Swansea because it's a fire alarm.
And the Swansea Mountain Messenger now you can pick up on any counter around.
Goosey counter at a lot of time.
And also I have a poem in it.
The right.
So I've been writing the poems.
Not my poems but poems that I pick up anti-war poems.
So poems that deal the fourth of July or longfellow or whatever.
You know poems that are not in copyright but they're printed in its hand.
It's a handout so nobody's after me with copyright.
So I get away with everything.
Yeah.
I have a complete collection over there.
Let me ask you two questions.
Do you want to stop for a second and say save these files.
I want to say digital files.
We'll back on.
So two related questions.
And one I guess is did you find people of like mind at Swansea and then the other question
is or in the greater community and that sort of a segue to talking about the Highlanders?
It's a liberal arts school.
So they accept a lot of New Yorker poems and upper class poems.
And liberal poems from various magazines.
Especially in these times in Chicago and progressive magazines, stuff like that.
And in between stuff.
A lot of stuff from American literature.
Modern American literature, ancient American literature.
It's a religious school, it's a physical school.
So I put in stuff where we were religious holidays, John and all the…
But I met when you came here as a faculty member.
Did you find other people on the faculty that had similar…
Yeah.
A lot of them were dropouts like the others, like the ones from the theology school.
And it gone to fairly conservative liberal arts colleges.
But the English department was not conservative.
Not conservative because they were hitched to the Swansea Review, which is the oldest
literary magazine in the country.
In the country, yeah.
And oldest constantly moving, going and is still going.
And I occasionally have one of my own poems in there in the Swansea Review.
And that's going strong and it's a good review.
Especially good for fairly conservative English people, but not that conservative, you
know.
A lot of them are unitarians, but a lot of them are pissed parliants too.
A lot of peaceful priests who dropped out, kind of become unitarians, things like that.
A lot of the peaceful priests were too liberal, peaceful priests.
And one of our famous graduates here in the class of 69 is Gene Robinson, the first
of Piscopal priests who is Bishop.
And it is a unitarian.
I mean, yeah, a Piscopal, no, he's not a unitarian.
He didn't go unitarian.
He became a Piscopalian.
He was the Church of God for a cameo swanney.
Okay.
It was a Piscopal school, which was supposed to be religious, you see.
But the use of Church of God and he was from the hills of Kentucky.
Yeah, he was his…
Yeah, I know.
Gene Robinson is great.
They wanted to run him back for an unarray degree because they're Piscopal Church because
half the Piscopal priests would leave, you see.
But the other half would stay.
They loved Gene Robinson.
They were trying to get him back.
So we students, we have a student, faculty student, what does it call the gay straight alliance
here.
But we have about a couple hundred gay students.
I'd say here, mostly women.
And because they finally let women in in 1969.
And I was on the board of trustees and I fought that battle long time.
And it fought the same battle that did bringing blacks in.
In the 50s, we fought to bring in women in the 60s.
It took ten years, most cases, to bring in first blacks and women.
And I was first black student, I mentioned in my…
I think I'm going to be tired there.
It was a top honest student from Alabama who became a federal judge when he got out.
It was first black graduate from the University of South.
And about the same time the women came in.
So the women came in when the blacks came in.
Well, the blacks came in little by little in during the 60s.
And they didn't get my cardiology straight.
And the blacks came in little by little during the 50s, one by one.
And in the 60s, they reluctantly let them in.
Because this peaceful church suddenly desegregated.
And a lot of churches moved out.
A lot of priests moved out.
A lot of our alumni moved out.
A lot of our alumni were priests.
So they wouldn't give an honorary degree to our one gay bishop in the whole angle of
church through the world.
And the teen Robinson came down a couple of times to speak to our gay straight alliance,
meeting and got the whole crowd there.
And he gave terrific speech.
I didn't knock out speech.
Everybody came.
They were there, they were all into that.
It was a wonderful occasion.
He gave some marvelous speech.
And almost as noticeable, notable as we again, a dear subject, which is when Martin Luther
came to Highlander.
And that was after the unions had kicked us out.
We had union representatives.
We had union workers here for Highlander up until the Supreme Court decision of 54.
If I could ask you to just back up just for a second and tell us a little bit about,
and just give us a little background on Highlander and how you became aware of it when you first
came down here.
Well, I had never heard of Highlander.
I had worked for Black Rights in Evanston and in the Army all my life and in my high school
and their place else.
But as followed, the riots up north horrified by them.
Because I'd been an orange bird and seen that segregation situation.
But there was no black there.
And so then I discovered that this little college, the first job I could get for one semester
after the war for two semesters actually.
And then it was extended for a lifetime.
It turned out.
But because I liked my teaching, even if they didn't like my politics.
And so I found my life's dedication, baked me to bring in blacks to the south and desegregate
the south and to work with Highlander.
So I'm a member of the board in that sense.
I'm an emeritus now on the board.
And I go to meetings every year.
And Highlander was at that time when you first got here, Highlander was located right
nearby.
Yeah.
It was the Union School, Union Organizing School in the south.
And best account of it in the straight literature is pretty much the University of North Carolina's
up to McClark book on the role of Highlander.
So it was coming to Highlander.
And then there are several books on Highlander.
And the best book on the history of Highlander and how it was founded by the unions and with
the unions and to bring in labor unions and the social gospel basically.
It was all the way back to 1905.
And the Miles Horton, it was a farm boy.
And what they call him, not a caretaker.
You know, stakeholder, what they call him?
Stakeholder?
Yeah.
Farm boy.
Oh, a sharecropper.
Sharecropper, that.
Yeah.
Sharecropper from Eastern Tennessee.
And so when he got, he was working for the YMCA in his little college down here.
His smart boy went high school, went to college, went to little country college and got a scholarship
to the famous, Anglican, I think, Seminary in New York City.
Field?
Is that Field Seminary?
Field Seminary.
And studied under Nieber and got to be a good friend of, of a friend and disciple of
Nieber and the student of Nieber and their communist, Episcopal priest there is hardy or something
like that.
And also the famous educator, Stakeholder's name Stakeholder's E.
Well, there's a union seminary there in the United States.
And Nieber is at the union, yeah.
And then behind the scenes was Evans, the famous educator.
Okay, I'm not sure.
Yeah.
He's the other radical Christian and educator.
He is my mother's study done to him.
And in any case, at the Evans and nursery academy.
And in any case, so those two educators, Reinhold Nieber and Jonathan Edwards.
No, that sounds right.
Jonathan Edwards is Scottish, so it's not him.
It's the English one, American one.
Anyway, here's one of the leading liberal, liberal, theologians at that time, near union.
It's connected to union.
And he was the radical educator, basically.
And the year outfit, the movement.
Student-interracial, ministry, yeah.
Yeah, very, very, very influenced by him.
Yeah.
Evans was his name.
It sounds right.
I have to go back and look.
I'm blanking on it too.
Yeah, I can't think of his name as a more precise would he anyway.
Well, so those were the two big influences on Miles, Miles Hartton.
And they told him to go to Chicago to Jane Adams.
Yeah, Jane Adams, and Hallhouse in Chicago.
And work with her.
So he did with her for a while.
And they gave him the idea that size zone Hallhouse, down to his home stayed in his home
area in eastern Tennessee.
Oh, because that's how.
Yeah.
And so he found out this liberal Memphis woman educator in Memphis, in Memphis State at
that time, had just retired.
And she was a missionary up here, up in the mountains, she had a home up in the mountains
at Montego.
And her house was off Montego in the country just outside of Montego.
And so she bought this big old firehouse.
And I have a picture of it, a photograph of it there, which is much smaller than the
Smithsonian, which was the original Highlander.
And actually it wasn't called Highlander then.
It was just a school for fire and people during the depression.
Well, before the depression in the 20s, very poor rural, very poor rural, poorest counties
in the country, Grendy County next door to us, Franklin County, Grendy County.
And Tracy City is the main city there.
And through this day, they don't really have one black family in Grendy County.
It was a pretty strong plan in Grendy County.
And they have the beginnings of Highlander.
And that's where Miles got his idea for a folk school.
Pretty much Miles modeled on the Danish folk schools, which was a model for your movement,
your religious movement, political religious folk schools, and Denmark.
And so Reinhold Nieber set Miles to Denmark to study those schools.
They stayed there for years or so.
And went back there, back to Nieber to Union, and then Nieber sent him to Jane Adams,
and then to Hallhouse in Chicago, and then put those all together, the Danish folk school
movement, and Hallhouse, and to do the same place, same kind of place in Grendy County,
in the rural county, in the very rural county.
A main crop was, of course, Poohenstein and Likert.
And the first nightclub in this area where we really went from Swanek to get the pooch.
And where my doctor, where I was lying on my back, getting shots in the hospital down
in Swanek hospital, was had grown up.
And at age 13, he'd been the bouncer for the first nightclub in Grendy County, his big
guy, 350 pounds.
And he'd tell me this at 3 o'clock in the morning when they're giving me shots.
And he'd tell me stories about what it was like being a 13-year-old bouncer, because he
wasn't done as a law, so they had a 13-year-old to throw the bumps out.
And one of the bumps he threw out was, to not be one of our football coaches, good guys,
very sweet, religious guy now, just retired.
And anyway, so we had great talks at 3 o'clock in the morning, I was giving me shots
about Grendy County, how we were allowed to kick out of Grendy County, so far, because
we had blacks, but Highlander chose to be right there in the middle of this dry moon
shining, very poor county, where they hated blacks, and they lynched blacks and things
like that, and they had moonshine, an Al Capone company.
And so he would come down from mountain moonshine, you know, the best moonshine in the mountains,
and down here, because they had plenty of time, you know, back in the woods here, and
we were really thick woods, I mean, these woods go way down in Alabama, almost down to
Gulf Coast.
These woods right across St. John's, and so it's a wonderful place to grow up, you know,
deer, panthers, and bobcats, and so we love it.
And I grew up along in Michigan, you know, in the woods long enough to kick Michigan,
nuts for me, as a big bird watcher still in there.
And so this was heaven, this was the utopia, this was Shangri-La, basically, for us.
A little college, a course, beautiful women, all these girls wanted to reach husbands,
come to this little, this school full of Episcopal priests, very religious, no blacks, so far,
all Republican.
Right.
You've got this radical, uh, school, yeah, the radical French teacher, and then you've
got a high wonder, you're right.
And went to PhD in French literature, and French literature is notoriously leftist, and
I love that.
You know, these wonderful Victor Hugo, you know, teaching against gun, teaching for gun control
is a great poem on against gun control.
It's really those pistols, but if you want to keep the people on your side, give them
a pistol.
This was written in 1870.
I put it in local papers, and I go, they want to even put it in New Yorker yet.
And Victor Hugo goes to radical for America's.
From the 1970s.
Would you like to take a break for a minute, and then pick up again?
Yeah, go back to the anti-war bit.
Yeah.
Because I had my war record cut out for me too, because I joined the wars as a league,
and they had an RCC here.
And so I did the small anti-war, anti-vietnam war movement among our best students, our PhD
students, and they turned pretty conservative, well, I still anglicant, but they're liberal
anglicant anyway.
But they're still anti-war, and Richard Tillinghast, you probably want to do him, he's
taking the house down here now.
He's down the street from us.
And he was a good student at that time, went down the highlander meetings with me, but
then turned kind of conservative and wrote for the New Republic for a while.
And now is the famous Southern poet, and he's joined forces with the agrarians.
They were not on our side.
Right.
Let's talk about highlander during the civil rights movement, years.
I know that you began your involvement really before the early stage there.
But maybe tell us a little bit about highlander moving, for example.
But I know that you were involved in a lot of the early workshops, a lot of the civil rights
movement activists whose names we recognize others, you came to know through Highlander.
Sure.
Yeah, the way I met up with these people first, I'd been to a Highlander meeting with
a group from a guy, which was the first meeting.
First meeting was with a group from NYC.
No, not NYC.
No, the University of Chattanooga.
They had a meeting of Monago.
And I was called a meeting with white people down from the University of Chattanooga,
the No Univisitive Knoxville.
You know, it's the Tennessee Knoxville, who were trying to integrate the University of
Tennessee in Knoxville.
And then with that same meeting, a group of students from the Tullahassee, who were trying
to bring in white students, black, callistic, what those two groups together to see how each
of them could integrate, white and black, and then it was a wonderful discussion, these
kids.
The kids ran the whole discussion themselves, how to do it, how to get it through the administration
and everything.
It was a beautiful visual lesson.
Yeah, he used the woods or anything else, whether it was John.
A visual lesson on how high underworked, how two groups posing fractions, working out
their problems together, and how to do it.
And it was fabulous.
I thought this was the way to act.
And Miles didn't interfere with anything.
He just let them go.
And they think a case need to say something or something.
As he did the Stokely-Cymeichel, but you got to do it yourself.
Yes, so I want to ask about that in a second, but what was his style?
What was Miles' style like in terms of getting a discussion going?
Oh, boy.
He'd get him in the fights for one thing.
He teased him.
A kid of him were pointing out in subtle ways that they weren't going far enough.
He had a huge mind.
It made some mad, too.
There wasn't always pleasant.
He was a very funny guy.
He'd tell jokes and things.
He was terrific when he was drunk.
He'd drink innumerable numbers of martinis.
He'd take a big picture of martinis and finish them by the end of the discussion.
So he's a wonderful talker.
Studs Terkel thought he was the greatest.
Look at the D. Deppy running in, basically.
So he was farmed.
When I was with him on the Seal's sorties where we had to fight the clan and things like
that, he was just wonderful.
I mean, he had answered everything.
He was always witty and kept things up beach and all.
He kept the dialogue going the right way.
And it was hard to live with.
And probably had fights with various mistresses or wives of people and so forth.
He was a mountain boy, really.
A farm boy.
A few martinis kind of going.
But was he a storyteller?
Studs Terkel thought he was the best storyteller he had ever enjoyed.
And so he was a joy to travel with him and just hear him talk.
Can you describe that meeting?
This would have been, I guess, after the Greensboro sit in, but before the meeting in Raleigh
in eastern 19th century.
That was a wonderful meeting.
This was a meeting at Highlander.
At Highlander.
And that's the one where the whole Greensboro bunch came in the Nashville bunch, made it together
in those of the two worlds came together and they just said, world basically.
And suddenly they realized what they had to do.
And then Miles just at the right moment said, you know what?
You guys got to do it yourself.
It's like that.
And it hit them like a shackle, I think.
They always thought, it was back and white together.
You know, and they don't sing those songs and march together and all that.
And we would march together.
You know, it was back and white together.
But when we marched in Chicago, we marched on state-seat in Chicago, 3,000 of us, 3,000
blacks.
And the few whites, the Chicago blacks, all the Chicago blacks, Mayor Daly's blacks, lined
up on the sides.
And all our, we blacks were from out of town.
We were from Detroit, Pills, Philadelphia, you know.
And California, San Francisco.
And they stayed curious and sapticed and everything.
But they would enjoy this.
We want to come join us and come join us.
And they would enjoy this.
And when we got to Crete Park, where Obama gave us acceptance speech in Chicago, you
know.
I wanted to shout out.
I wasn't there, but I was watching it until this is where we met 10 years ago, you know,
3,000 of us.
And shouted Mayor Daly down.
We wouldn't let him talk, you know.
And I wasn't a member of that, but the Chicago Socialist got in on that one.
And they were largely black.
And but in any case, that was the reception in Chicago after the Cicero riots.
And the Chicago, the Cigarettes were pretty scared.
A freight of Mayor Daly and freight of their handouts from Alderman and the blacks were
for us.
And the whites could understand why we were against the NAVACP because they thought the
NAVACP, the Blacks were all in the place for people.
They, whites had no clue.
I was really going on about division, you know.
But the NAVACP was pretty straight for one thing.
And too straight for the Socialists and not straight enough for others.
And when I got a member of the board, briefly, at one of our national meetings with the NAVACP
and I met with Roger Wilkinson Company.
You know, I said after the meeting, I said, why don't you recognize the, and the,
are the snake and the snake and the southern organizations.
And Roger Wilkins said, well, we'll recognize them.
We'll take what they have to give us.
But we won't recognize them publicly.
We'll do it privately.
They think it's mud, you know, as they're Washington.
So hierarchy.
So let's talk about the end.
We'll come back to Highlander.
But let's stay with NAVACP for a minute because I know that you were quite involved with
a chapter.
Yeah.
Can you tell us that?
Yeah, that was very involving.
Because of course that chapter was written out of the newspapers.
I mean, the banner would not publish anything about it.
The cap times was different.
Chattenew time, Johnny.
And Chattenew time was taken back to Wisconsin.
Chattenew time would say, always preface Highlander by the controversial Highlander.
They stayed in the middle pretty much.
But they reported our news, except the bad news.
And the banner went to town of the bad news.
So I know that you were involved with the NAVACP.
Was that in this area?
Yeah.
So I started the chapter under the supervision of Septimaclack.
And that was under the issue and she was working for Highlander.
She was the education director.
And she was starting in the last chapter of the South.
And often against the grain, the black establishment thought they were liberal until the end of
the last three years until Highlander organized it.
Septimaclack.
Septimaclack was the most sweet, persuasive, and nice person.
And I just love her.
I think she is the goddess of the whole movement, basically.
And blacks don't give a credit for that.
And you can tell by that how cow'd in there.
And we can help if they can't hear because she desegregated our Swany Chapel and really
through us faculty members, the Swany faculty and the faculty of the Pistil Church and
seminaries.
And the Pistil priest, a lot of priestess left the church because of this.
And the concert was broken in half.
So what was the reaction when she came to church to address the...
Half of it.
We had about David Deeds was tolerated.
He was a little bit too fundamentalist with him.
And he thought he was a cat of a hick.
He was Chapel Hill, where everybody sent their kids after going there.
But still, they thought of him as pretty fundamentalist.
Sometimes, you know, he wouldn't support World War II and stuff like that.
And so after David, they stayed there, probably the usual full church congregation was there.
That December day, when he said, ten, those two ladies.
He's over there.
We welcome him.
And so they went down the front seat.
They didn't know what to do in the Pistil Church.
Went to the stand.
They went to kneel.
Right.
They didn't dare look around.
They weren't going to sit in the back seat.
So they walked right down front and everybody politely stayed in their seat.
And at the end of the service, the half of the church got up and left.
Never came back.
These were mountain people.
These were village people.
They were townspeople.
And when we came out trials, in the end of the eight seasons, the end of the ACP, led
by two brave guys I've ever run into.
Actually, Avon Williams was the brave one.
He came down every week through the trial for two years.
You can imagine that audience in the killer of the Mockingbird, of all fights in the
Franklin County court on the bottom, all blacks in the small, male community.
That's true.
He was on.
And he knew that everybody in the audience was carrying a gun.
But the police said, that's not worth.
We're not going to have this happen here.
We're not going to have a massacre of Franklin County take place this day.
And it would have if they hadn't been there.
And they stopped it.
And that's for two years.
Every court hearing, two years, every week for two years.
Can you just start from the beginning and tell us what the court case was?
The court case was that I knew I believed they were going to disaggregate after the Supreme
Court case.
But everybody in the South was stalling.
And for one reason or another, you're kidding their lawyers to find some reason.
And of course, the meeting of South Carolina legislature and all that stuff, and their
party, the Southern party, what did they call it.
And by that time, John Bruce Society had gotten in the app and they had gotten a lot of followers
in the South.
And a lot of followers in the South Carolina particularly in Tennessee.
And they had marches in Tennessee.
And you probably saw Nashville, the movie Nashville, where it starts off at the job
bridge meeting and all that.
And the organizer for the Southern, this particular area, was a student, a millionaire
student at the college.
It's not that bad.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
And what was his name?
Another name I can't think of at the moment.
But he was organizing the segregationists?
Yeah.
And John, the John Birch Society.
He's getting these rich students to join the John Birch Society.
And I feel them did.
And they had one John Birch Society meeting here in Swansea, and just outside of Swansea,
at Cheap's restaurant.
And Cheap had that restaurant to soak the preach John Birch's dogma to them, to the students
when they came in for beer, because that's the only place they could get beer.
And so he would go out to Highlander parking lot and take license plates, all the cars
there and send them to the FBI.
And FBI wanted them.
The FBI was investigating Highlander.
And it had a lot of Highlander spelled mileshorts, same along.
And you can see their record over there, but it's all blacked out.
It's over in our archives.
It's freedom of information.
I've yet to go look up my record in the freedom of information.
I'm sure it's quite interesting.
Because when we sat in the tubbies, one of the places we could get beer, where the
students could go and get beer, the blacks had to come in the back door and throw a beer.
And the some of them were janitors.
And we were known by these students, and they go back to talk with the black janitors.
And they'd be kicked out.
We'd go back there.
And so we got even on with him on that case, because the tubbies was a nationally registered
place, beer place, beer house.
And so we called in Avan, and he called in the FBI.
Well, the FBI sent two investigators down.
And then investigators investigated not the guys, not tubbies, but us.
We started that, we wanted to see.
The kind of down to tubbies started to sit in.
And so we were on there for a long time.
And then we had a big record in FBI, but I had bothered to go.
I'd be telling, anyway, we'll be back down anyhow.
So I've been here in a long time.
So I've been here 40 years, more than 40 years.
And so I must have some records here.
I'm sure.
And but it's fun, you know.
There's been on the right side of the law for the first time.
Absolutely.
And see the lot.
So that part?
That part?
No.
So that court case was a desegregation?
Was it about desegregating the schools?
Yeah.
We called Avan Williams and Louby and Williams from Nashville.
We went down to their office on the canal and the river in Nashville, down the slums
kind of.
And there was a fascinating trip.
Because Mrs. Fowler, her leader, went with us.
And she was a black woman from Swansea.
And she was another hero.
She worked closely with Septima Clark.
She should be written up too.
She ran the NAVACP chapter, starting with 1969.
No, 1967.
We had that meeting with Martin Luther King so far in Rosa Parks.
You've seen the photograph of that.
Although I'm on the back, standing against the window.
Right.
And this is the photograph that was used to sort of build boards all over.
Yeah, to paint Highlander as a communist.
King at the Communist Focus Goethe says, big photograph.
And he can see me standing against the wall.
And my students just come in with a picture and they're saying, hey, it's just all you
at Highlander there that day.
They wouldn't go to Highlander because nobody would go to Highlander.
Nobody to this day goes to Highlander.
A few brave people have houses there because they're cheap.
And they've driven the Highlander people out.
And I think Lake is good fishing.
And Highlander always permitted everybody to come and fish there.
So fishermen came in, period.
What happened to...
So after Highlander got run out of time, what happened to the land itself?
It's been sold cheap by little houses, waitresses, and Madigal and people like that.
And the important is summer vials.
It's a summer of Madigal.
It's a little country summer.
This one I'll take you when you come down.
Because we're seeing the graves instead of the Clark, that's something that we're right.
But May Justice is grave.
You know May Justice about May Justice, I guess.
And May Justice and the whole Horton family is buried there.
Oh, come.
And so I always take them there first.
And we finally got them just last year to put up a highway marker there.
Oh, good.
About the history of Highlander.
Two sides.
So it's about a mile on beyond.
You can go there, just pass it two minutes, see it on your way out.
It's a mile beyond Madigal and the Jesper road.
The road to actually a Tracy City road.
It goes straight from Madigal to Tracy City.
And a little ways up, you'll see a marker, historical marker, on the left side of the road
one of those grey historic marker with a sign up there.
And you turn on that little road.
And then you take another turn, two turns and you have to add Highlander.
You're at the cemetery.
The cemetery's right across from Highlander.
And the Old Highlander is mainly bricks and mortar just from the fire that slept.
You can use the wood so you're a giant if you want to go there.
Oh, sorry.
And so that's very accessible if you have lunches at Madigal.
You can just sit off like that and go to Highlander and the cemetery and see what's left
to the lake.
The lake is still good.
People still fish in it.
And they go over there, there's the fish.
Not to build or anything.
They could get by their old library, which is a historical monument.
I got the historical monument people down from Washington to investigate it.
But it's been too gentrified now.
These little houses have been built around it.
It's become a little suburb, really.
And what's left about it, Miles' beautiful house was he built out of Mountain Stone himself.
It was burned down by the parish over there.
The Presbyterians come in and patch up the parish under instructions by some minister who
went to his grave.
Biggie pardoned God for doing that.
Urging his parish to burn it down.
And regretted it the rest of his life.
So that's where they were the trip.
But I get a group stand from Alaska, from all over Europe.
I want to see it.
The place where really the one spot where the whole movement started, the active movement
of it.
They really shitted the fan.
They see it be there.
Well let me ask you then, this is a perfect segue then to a sort of a big overview
question that I was going to ask you, which is, can you sort of give an assessment of
Highlanders' place in the movement?
Oh God.
What?
Yeah, it's finally getting back in.
Nobody would even mention Highlander for years, until just recently, till Obama got in
there basically.
And suddenly, suddenly it became history, American history, you know.
And now everybody talks about Highlanders.
It's kind of embarrassing.
They all want to hear about it.
People wouldn't speak to me for years, you know.
They thought I was wrecking the faculty in the, in the, our dean called the Red Dean.
It was from, from Virginia East Coast, the Gulf Coast, not the Gulf Coast, the Atlantic
Coast, from shore, Virginia Shore.
Anyway, Highlander, he was one of our strictest, not only anti-gay, but anti-black.
And so I fought him for 20 years until he finally said, I'm sorry to go against Dr. Bates
for the first time in my life, but I'm forgetting rid of cars that's wanting.
Which he always had.
And I had no, no, not like all the time.
I've been trying to get rid of cars, that's why I was, so years, that was a great thing
I hear.
Good students and no cars, you know.
And good, good class, good teachers.
And very strict adherence to the old, you know, the old, you know, real English teaching,
real language teaching.
Every English major had to take French, which was great for me, because I could teach
them all these seditious things, Spanish books.
And having reading, seditious French books, and they'd sneak out the marquee de saide,
which we have in our library, Adam Reserve.
The French liberalism of French law, the system was something that lay.
Oh, very, very definitely.
Everybody in France knows French law, the system, and nobody in France is allowed to read it.
And they have a safeguard committee in France that keeps the books out of the national
libraries.
But they're thick in other libraries.
I mean, everybody knows these books.
Everybody can buy them in certain bookstores.
You have to know which bookstores you know.
But like Richard Hugo and his own radicalism.
Well, his own radicalism was socialist, basically.
And pretty much your socialism, Christian socialism.
And that's why that poem about against the gun cellists should be publicized across
America now.
And I've sent it to a nation.
I've sent it to New York public.
And they won't publish it.
You know?
So strange.
There's so much under the power of the Gundabi.
And only for historic interest.
I mean, it's a cup of milk.
Oh, geez.
It's still seditious.
Yeah.
Somehow seditious.
And mainly for one passage, which I translated here.
And you can read the first two lines of it.
I can read the first two lines if we're all camera to you because it should be known.
It's the answer.
And through the biblical light.
You're, you're, you got the microphone.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
I could read aloud.
And then you wouldn't be talking to me.
I could do a death.
Yeah, we can deal with that.
Because it's a wonderful passage, really.
But everybody knows it in France, but nobody will publish it, you see.
Since the Marquis de Sade.
It's actually, since not the Marquis de Sade so much, it's much more, much more blasphice
than this statistic.
It's from the auntie's youth team, not the youth team, of Sade.
But the auntie's youth team, by a steep lot of a ton.
He wrote, as an answer to Sade, write a pornographic book that was not statistic.
He thought he could.
Well, they can't in this passage.
He's written it in the White House.
Not white, but everybody knows it anyway, but it's still banned in France.
But it's published in France in the Underground Book series, The Greenback Books and things
like that, you know.
And especially at James Joyce, Incorporated Bookstore here in Paris.
If you want to read a great book, well, there's several great books about that.
I got a lot of stuff.
Most of my stuff is that, because my office is up my cabin up there.
I can take you up there, because nobody's up there.
And show you my library.
Yes.
Well, we have to see that.
So, let me just ask a couple more questions as wave wrapping up, I guess.
And just another, I want to ask you again about Highlander's role.
So, there's a sociologist named Alden Morris who wrote this book, The Origins of the
Civil Rights Movement, is one of the first sort of way to history.
Well, he was the head of the group, the Episcopal group in Atlanta.
The John Morris, is John Morris?
No, this is Alden Morris, who is from the Chicago.
He may be related.
The John Morris is the Episcopal Society for Decegigation.
Oh, okay.
And so he should be known by you guys.
Okay.
So, we had a blow up over another blow up in the 60s about deseggigating our inn.
That's one inn, that was.
Sorry, much so on tape.
Yeah, well, I was just going to say Alden Morris does write about Highlander.
He was actually very early on, reckoning with Highlander.
But he called it, he said, Highlander, he talked about whole house, places like that,
he called movement halfway houses.
Basically, they were places that trained and inspired others and sent them on.
Very much so.
Yeah.
And that was basically the role of Highlanders.
And Hellhouse had a big influence on him.
And Miles.
He went up to Hellhouse.
Yeah.
So I didn't know that he had taken, so he sort of took that lesson and brought it to Hellhouse.
Yeah, he took, he started with basically with Episcopal Academy, New York Academy, New
York Seminary.
Right.
That's where he went.
And then he went from there to, well, and from neighbor to Chicago.
From Chicago to, guys, I think he went to there, he went to basically, they let him know
about, uh, uh, Mon Eagle.
Right.
That retired college professor at Mon Eagle and Highlander, because he'd back-highlander.
And he started working with poor, you know, poor folks in this area and never really stopped.
Right.
I mean, Highlander is still kind of focused on working for the people from the people.
That's right.
Very much so.
And very, very upset that I pushed sometimes NAACP stuff at him.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
Because he didn't want to work for NAACP.
He didn't want to do anything official.
He went to St.P.
And he went to the grassroots.
He really, to this day, to the end of his life, he was a, uh, what do they call it?
A new Christian, uh, what a, the Christian left Jesus Christians.
Why am I waking up at this?
After your own movement.
Social Gospel.
Yeah.
He's a social Gospel.
And that's why he wouldn't trust these people.
That's why he said you got to go with the, with the blacks.
Yeah.
Because he didn't realize how conservative so many blacks were.
Right.
So tell us again, because we were off camera before that, and we started talking about this
before, but we'll come, we're just coming back to it now.
That meeting which preceded the Raleigh, uh, Shaw University meeting at which SNCC was
officially founded.
But this is a meeting at Highlander.
And what, what, what Miles said to Stokely Carmichael was?
Yes, to a big discussion.
And one of our students, a poet I mentioned, uh, uh, Dick Tillinghast.
He's now bought a house here.
And there's a big famous poet now, right for nation and New Republic and so on.
Anyway, uh, he had brought to that meeting with all these blacks, John Lewis and Stokely
Carmichael and, uh, Barry and so forth, there, um, would, um, he brought to that meeting.
He said, you guys don't know Thorough, they don't know who, who Thorough, well, he didn't
know.
SA had civil disobedience.
So he dashed back to Swati eight miles and got his book as civil disobedience tore back
to the meeting and, and to just around and so introduced that, that book, uh, SNCC
and so on.
Now that's when, uh, they moved the black pants that started.
That was the spark, basically.
I don't know if that book had anything to do with it.
I don't know if they even read that book and out of it kind of.
These black pants, these were not into reading white books, you know.
But anyway, they started the black pants that's right then, that month.
You know, uh, they, they bar snake, you mean?
Yes, they do.
Yeah.
And the march on, on, on, on, coming, coming about on, uh, um, Ole Miss, you know, the
Courter store and all that stuff.
And, um, and so, uh, that's what, that was the spark, really.
And what, and can you just tell us again the quote, what Miles said.
Miles said, you know, you guys, you gotta do it yourself.
You know, the white's a lot stick with you.
And he was right too.
Even though it would be about five or six years before.
Oh yeah, that came true, but he saw that.
Yeah, he saw it.
And Stokeley said, that's it, that's right.
And when they came down to Highland, they did come down to Highland.
The group of, uh, uh, panthers from Chicago, they brought other guns.
And we had a sitting rule, no guns.
I mean, they didn't realize how thick and fast guns were and how big the clan was there.
They'd already burnt stuff down in the, in Knoxville, you know.
And stuff, so, uh, we said no guns, you know.
And he said, sorry guys, we'd love to talk to you and talk with you.
And, yeah, we're on your side.
We just had to take guns.
It would be out of here in a minute.
We'd be burned down in a minute, you know.
Right.
And that was in the end.
The clan was pretty in front of our house up there, which was in the black district of,
the old black district, which they, uh, what is it, they turned for it, uh, urbanly renewed
after, which meant moving that one house out.
Right.
It was a big old house, so you think about it?
Knoxville on the river, and the river side on that back road, crossed with a cement plant
on the river beautiful area.
I took a take the bus up to the Kay Street in, uh, Knoxville and get off the bus, walk
about six blocks down the river to the hotland area right there.
And the Knoxville college, black college there, kids would never come over to the near
the place.
But the black people, a few of the black people, it was right back of the black press
for tear in church.
And, uh, on the top of the bluff there, right above us, uh, it would come down from
the church.
And I and Esau Jenkins and Andrew Young would stay at that church, at the little black
church on the end of the church.
It's so much fun watching Esau Jenkins with this huge pot, taking this stripping naked,
you know, and shutting around in the neighborhood.
And talking with us about Highlander and about, uh, I love to go down to John's Island
off Chashson.
And we took a busload of bags over to, uh, black kids from, uh, uh, John's Island
over to see the famous rich island over there in Charleston off the coast.
And it's all white only, island, coast white.
Oh, right.
This is all white only anyway.
We took them through Charleston on a bus tour.
But we got off the bus, we followed by groups of white kids, you know, saying, hey, that's
a beautiful black cow.
They sleep with everybody and all and stuff like that and they're grazing us.
And boy, they did want to mix this up.
They were afraid of us.
They were afraid we'd take after them.
But they were during us and Mrs. Clark was in the midst of us and was saying, he's white.
Why don't they learn their manners for you guys saying it.
She's so white.
Right.
That was for you.
She's so used to it.
Right.
And that polite, what it was, sexist for Southern boys.
She gives these nice, white, nice black boys.
And when we got to Sullivan's Island, the famous white, uh, Gold Coast there, uh, we were
met by two young men, white men, uh, saying, sorry, this is all women's guys and two
hallways.
We mostly, uh, black men, but some white women, some white women, and, and, and, and, and,
uh, they addressed, and I think don't want to go there.
I can't remember.
A guy caravan was there.
He was living down in Charleston.
Oh, guy caravan.
Yeah.
Kind candy caravan.
And they're little boy.
Yeah.
And, uh, in the case of them.
So they, uh, they, I stayed with them.
I stayed with these two.
And that was nice.
And I took, uh, and the one time Martin Luther King came to Charleston and he gave a lecture
then.
It's closely guarded on the white side of Charleston and the big white, yes, it was a Baptist
church, I'm not sure.
Uh, church, it was a black church, that's right.
It was a black church.
And it was closely guarded by the white police.
And when we had a meeting on the beach, we went to the black beach, North part of the
Mertle Beach is black.
And just a little section where black houses were.
And, uh, so we did have a desegregated meeting there.
And we were ringed by about, I'd say, 12, 15 cop cars.
The whole meeting, the meeting lasted all day.
Went around and around.
As they left, there was a boy, a stiff.
We were talking, you know, planning to sit in and stuff like that.
And they were going around and around us waiting for us to burn something down.
Nothing exciting happened.
But they were just keeping watch, keeping their presence there.
Do you have the board of violence in the field?
Yeah, I got on the board in 58 and, uh, never got off.
So I'm America's now.
But I go to the homecoming and, uh, I get periodic board meetings and stuff.
You're a president of the board?
I was for a hot day.
All during the 60s.
Yeah.
That's when I went down to Jackson and, um, inspected things.
So how often did you get, did you get over there?
Well, this is the six, eight miles down the road.
Okay.
From here.
And, um, so I would go once a week or twice a week.
So I was going to go.
And how about when it relocated?
When it relocated, it took me six hours to get up there.
It's a cause to get back.
I was teaching five days a week.
Six days a week.
I taught six days a week about it.
I was going to go to the south end of the morning.
And we required, we required classes at the morning.
So I didn't have much time off because you had to read all the stuff and, uh, and those
board meetings.
That's a long time.
Right.
You know, they're all talking.
You used to talk and you'd sit around a circle from all parts of the south and west and
places in Chicago and New York Boston.
And so, so those guys got a lot to say.
I was going to say, Highlander meetings went on for a while.
Yeah.
And they were good meetings.
Better meetings then.
When I got off head, big head of the board, I insisted they stopped typing them up and
returning a minute of reports because they sent them in advance.
People would say they read them and they hadn't read them.
They hadn't had time to read them and gotten off their jobs in time or had run thoroughly
and so forth.
So they'd bring up all kinds of stuff that we'd normally, when we had oral board meetings
like this.
They'd ask the questions right there then and they'd want the truth and they'd get
it the truth.
And we would just come back from a field meeting, you know, in Jackson, Mississippi or I went
to another one in Memphis and others would have lots of say, you know.
We would put in the report.
The report would try and thus be compared with what we're talking about.
Right.
You know, they could ask questions, you know.
And so the board meetings have changed great deals.
They're good because they're good people, these people are doing things and they're organizing
things and they're organizing gay action in the black action too.
So we tell them that the black stuff worked with us too and that's been very interesting.
I know this is a strong focus these days.
Yeah, this would dick us because it's a same damn movement.
It's still a freedom movement.
And we still sing the same songs and what's this name?
The other emeritus, along with me from Mississippi, whose head of the Southern Echo group, anyway,
he's a great singer and he always opens every song, every meeting with a song and he has
great storytellers, storytelling, Justin, he's just leap out at me after living with him
for 50 years.
But in any case, it's been a wonderful board and the bunch down from New York and Boston
so far they're really good and they stick to business and they do the business and a lot
of blacks and South, not a lot of blacks from North Carolina and Atlanta.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum
of African American History and Culture.